[Music]
that's thirteen-year-old Gianna Bryant
showing off her skills in a moving video
her mom Vanessa Bryant shared on
Instagram Monday morning the footage
brings Gigi's natural athleticism to
life
and highlights the special bond she
shared with her dad Kobe Bryant with the
video vanessa pent an emotional caption
about her state following the loss of
her husband and 13 year old daughter the
37 year old writes in part quote my
brain refuses to accept that both Kobe
and Gigi are gone I can't process both
at the same time adding it's like I'm
trying to process Kobe being gone but my
body refuses to accept my gg will never
come back to me it feels wrong GG's a
basketball player she is that she's in
it does she have that inner focus like
her daddy
yeah she's she's just don't go killer
out there yeah at both ends of the floor
she plays defense as well as offense man
she competes Vanessa continues quote why
should I be able to wake up another day
when my baby girl isn't being able to
have that opportunity I'm so mad she had
so much life to live god I wish they
were here and this nightmare would be
over praying for all of the victims of
this horrible tragedy please continue to
pray for all Vanessa
ends her post beloved by fans around the
world
Kobe Bryant had transcended the game
he embodied excellence achieved an
aspiration for millions of fans
everywhere
[Music]
Koby Gianna and seven others died in a
helicopter crash in Calabasas California
on January 26 Vanessa
broke her silence three days later
posting this family photo on Instagram
since then she shared a number of
tributes including photos and videos
from the memorial held at GG school he
also posted this pic of the LA Lakers
tribute to the black mamba and his
mamacita duty game over the weekend
Vanessa shared an adorable video of her
seven month old daughter Capri riding my
cocoa beam she looks just like my Gigi
with her daddy's eyes and posted about a
public memorial that's being held for
Kobe and Gianna at the Staples Center on
February 24 my mentality is it's a way
of life a source tells et that vanessa
has been surrounded by her family and
friends but she feels almost numb to
everything she married Kobe when she was
18 and she never expected to live life
without him so it's going to take time
the source adds quote right now she's
taking time to be with her girls
responsibilities always inspire and try
to take some of the life lessons that we
have learned and share those with the
next generation so that they can start
their journey with a Lego